the general secretary and the president
are not involved in this procedure as to
the names that were published in the
media this morning I am unable to
comment responsible and this is also
obvious in the press release of the
general attorney then you would have to
address to mr. and mrt you have his data
to get in touch with him or if you have
questions to the federal office of
justice you have the person to get in
touch with the photo Polly now You
certainly have questions when it comes
to the questions and the answers there's
hardly anything we can say as to the
current procedure I can only say nothing
more nothing less than that what has
been said and written by the federal
Attorney's Office about an hour ago and
let me tell you that in spite of the we
are very happy about what is happening
right now it is once again unfortunately
FIFA suffering under these circumstances
it is certainly a difficult moment for
us you know we have the Congress about
to start lots of questions was the
Congress take place will it not take
place of course Congress will take place
one thing has nothing whatsoever to do
with the other then there may be
dissenting views on that but from our
side this Congress definitely will be
carried out but taking into account this
current procedure but this is not
related to Congress